imagine that one day all of the clocks
and computers on earth broke and all the
calendars disappeared how would you keep
track of how much time had passed well
you could look to the moon humans have
used the moon to keep track of time for
thousands of years it isn't a
coincidence that the word moon is
related to the word month in old english
the moon is earth's only natural
satellite a natural satellite is a
naturally occurring body that orbits a
planet
some of the planets in our solar system
have more than 50 satellites or moons
but the earth just has one the moon does
not generate its own light
we can see the moon from the earth
because it is partially lit by the light
from the sun in fact moonlight is just
sunlight reflected from the moon onto
earth the moon takes about 27 days to
make a full orbit around earth and as it
does the lit part of the moon appears to
change shape to us here on earth these
shapes are called the moon phases or
lunar phases
so why do we see different lunar phases
well the 27 days it takes the moon to
orbit the earth once it is the same
amount of time it takes the moon to
rotate on its axis once
this means that the same side of the
moon is always facing us at the same
time the sun always lights up half of
the sphere of the moon however the side
of the moon that's facing us isn't
always the same part of the moon that
the sun lights up this causes the moon
to appear to have different shapes or
faces in the sky depending on the time
of the month let's take a closer look at
the moon's phases
first we have the new moon which happens
when the moon is closest to the sun in
its orbit during this phase the lift
side of the moon is completely facing
away from earth so it looks like the
moon has disappeared in a day or two
we'd be able to see a little sliver of
moon in the sky over the next few days
the crescent moon will appear to get
bigger and bigger when the moon appears
to get bigger from one day to the next
we say that the moon is waxing so this
phase of the moon is called the waxing
crescent moon you might notice that
sometimes we can still see the rest of
the moon in the shadow this is because
the earth reflects sunlight onto the
moon just like the moon reflects light
onto earth eventually the moon appears
to change shape so much that it isn't a
crescent anymore but a half circle in
the sky this is called a first quarter
moon there are two ways to think about
why this phase is called the quarter
moon even though it looks like the moon
is half illuminated the moon is a sphere
so we can only ever see half of the moon
from earth during a quarter moon the
moon forms a right angle with earth in
the sun this means that we see a
half-lit portion of the half of the moon
that's always facing us it's half of a
half so it's a quarter also a first
quarter moon occurs when the moon is a
quarter of the way through its new cycle
next there's the waxing gibbous moon the
word gibbous comes from the latin word
meaning humpback once the moon is
farthest from the sun in its orbit the
full sunlit side of the moon faces earth
we call this phase the full moon but the
moon is not done yet it's only finished
half of the cycle
next we have the same phases but in
reverse as the moon appears to get
smaller and smaller we say that it's
waning the full moon appears to shrink
and then we see a waning gibbous
then there's the third quarter moon this
happens when the moon is three-quarters
of the way down with its cycle and the
moon forms another right angle with the
sun in the earth the moon appears to
shrink even more and it becomes a waning
crescent
and the cycle starts anew with another
new moon even though the moon completes
an orbit every 27 days the lunar phases
actually repeat about every 29.5 days
this is because the earth is revolving
around the sun while the moon completes
its orbit so the moon has to travel a
little extra to catch up
the moon isn't just something beautiful
to look at in the sky or just an easy
way to keep track of time the moon's
gravity controls the tides which are the
rise and fall of water in oceans lakes
and rivers tides allow for unique
ecosystems like tide pools to exist and
we can use the tides to create
electricity in tidal power plants the
moon also helps keep earth's axis stable
without it our planet would wobble more
dramatically on its axis over long
periods of time which would change up
our weather and our seasons so even
though your calendar is pretty unlikely
to spontaneously combust tomorrow you
could still thank the moon for being
such a stabilizing influence and good
companion to our planet